do the s23s cameras beat the iPhone 14
and can they keep up with the excellent
pixel 7 Pro well but he went out and
took a bunch of pictures Max and I have
not seen them yet and we're going to be
voting on the best ones so get a piece
of paper and a pen but with us and let
us know in the comments here's the first
shot this is my son Eugene early in the
morning what do you guys think what's
better is that one out of focus it looks
a little bit blurry on all of them does
look blurry this one looks a little too
dark for me so I like the middle yeah I
definitely like the middle I like that
it's a lot brighter than the others but
the HDR is better like it's less blown
out outside as well well let's see well
that's the iPhone and actually the
galaxy s23 is the only one that lets you
shoot with the 50 megapixel sensor and I
guess it didn't help it win all right
here you go here's a couple of twins wow
that's tough lighting oh my goodness
very tough lighting yeah this is the
ultra wide lens on all of them so here
it's back focused again oh you see the
faces are all blurred out the middle and
the right one both look really good but
I think I see a little more detail in
the center one I agree I like the center
all right the center is the pixel 7 Pro
yeah it looks nice and sharp all right
this is my son Eli he recently started
walking now there's something
interesting here I'll explain in a
second yeah that one I could see it's
all blurred out but it's motion blur too
slow of a shutter on that one I have a
question what color are your floors is
it are they are they warm or are they
darker and cooler they're kind of in the
middle honestly
yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna Focus
um that one's supposed to be white not
super warm or green let's see
pixel 7 Pro in the center iPhone on the
left and the Galaxy s23 actually shot a
couple different times the motion blurge
is so bad it doesn't snap it instantly
like the others do moving on to the next
one we have a selfie I'm gonna go for
the center one it looks natural the face
it looks like it's nice and in Focus I
agree the center one definitely looks
the most balanced
Center is the s23 one for the Samsung
moving on we have a little toy Cactus
this looks like a zoom photo yep I
believe it's 2x it seems like the one on
the right has the most detailed but I do
like the extra pop of color on the one
on the left so I'll go for that one
interesting I like the one on the right
more I think the left one just looks a
little unnatural to me
okay
s23 and pixel no love for the iPhone
next up we have a main camera photo this
is kind of for HDR since you see it's so
bright in the background I like how
bright they are on the left side right
here it definitely brings out the
subject but I'm actually gonna go for
the one in the middle because it just
looks a little more natural more true to
life yeah this is tough I like that the
left one was bright and they really pop
but I see more detail in the center
I think I'm gonna go with the left
though
all right iPhone and pixels all right
this is I believe a 3X I don't know what
happened to that right side one it's so
flat super flat very little detail very
little contrast it gets better as you go
to the left and it looks like it's
Sunset so the ground there the asphalt
should be a warmer color so I'm going
with the left yeah the left one is
really balanced the center one the darks
are kind of crushed but the left one
oh my goodness Google's doing a great
job all right we got Eli right here this
is also sunset time there's a little bit
of differences here but it looks like
it's a portrait shot right yep here we
have all the legs kind of blurred out I
don't know what isn't really in Focus
some stuff is some stuff isn't the right
one looks super weird it looks
over sharpened something and I don't see
really any blur except for like kind of
this right here the left one looks
really really nice but I honestly like
the center one as well like
stylistically I agree it looks magical
special but the focus is all over the
place and the detail is also a little
bit lost it's a great photo but I think
the left one looks the most like a DSLR
shot all right you both voted for the
s23 on the left now the difference here
is that we have 3x portrait on the pixel
and the Galaxy s23 but the iPhone can
only do one X portrait so I got closer
which is why the blur is so off I wish
they added that digitally yeah you could
do that other phones do that next up we
have the main camera right here just for
kind of detail these all look very
similar but for me it's between the left
and the center and I like the extra pop
of contrast that the left has with this
kind of shot I agree I'm voting for the
left we got the iPhone this time it's
interesting how the saturation is higher
than the other ones yeah didn't used to
be like that that's for sure okay this
is a very close Zoom shot 30 x 30X yeah
30X Zoom well they all look kind of bad
yeah one looks the worst right here and
here you have extra contrast added
around the letters that are not there
that's fake but you know what if I need
to zoom into a license plate or
something else I would want to be able
to read it the best so the center for me
absolutely yeah same and here you go
that is the original image as you can
see the iPhone only goes up to 5x while
the other two can do 30X that's a pain I
will say it's a pain that they only do
5x still no telephoto in 2023 I know
it's also crazy that the pixel has a 5x
lens in it where that thing has a 3X but
it looks a lot better all right next up
we have a main camera portrait this one
is bad
Yep this one is really bad I see so much
detail in the center but man is
everything blue yeah and the one on the
right looks like it's a little wider of
a lens the blur looks pretty natural
um I'm voting for the right I'm still
going for the center I would just adjust
the color
right so iPhone in the center s23 on the
right the Galaxy is too natural where
like it doesn't brighten it up enough so
dark in the picture yeah yeah the pixel
is just too natural needs a little more
processing now to bring up the face all
right we have a selfie here against the
Sun so kind of HDR difficult here that
one looks good to me yeah it's supposed
to be warm it's a sunset you want the
image look warm that looks the worst
yeah out iPhone nice that looks good wow
next up this is a portrait Zoom portrait
now I like the warmth during a sunset
but that is just way too much for me it
looks bad uh that one's not too bad but
I'm going for the right looks the most
natural and has decent detail to me the
right one just kind of looked flat with
everything kind of going
to go it's actually gonna go with the
left one do you like this edging I don't
want to change your mind do you like The
Edge detection it looks like it's some
cut off thing right no but the others
look too flat let's see
so the left was actually the iPhone the
right was the pixel and the crazy thing
is this is a 3X portrait which means
the iPhone was a 1x which I cropped in
like crazy three times and you see it's
bad Edge detection huh that one too next
up we have a portrait shot with a
newborn baby this is Ivan not his baby
not my baby I'm gonna go with the one on
the right the left one definitely messed
up like cutting stuff out and the
texture on the skin looks a little bit
weird compared to the other ones yeah
the right one looks very natural you
could see a lot of detail though yeah I
completely agree right we have the
iPhone on the right nice portrait shot
as long as you're just keeping it with
the 1X we have a detail shot right here
oh okay so two of these phones have 50
megapixel main lenses and one has a 12.
so two of these phones have 50 megapixel
sensors the iPhone has a 12 but the
pixel doesn't let you record in 50 where
the Samsung does and this isn't 50. yeah
let's see if we can tell a difference to
me this one looks the least detailed
the metal on is in the middle and the
one on the right looks the most detailed
let's see if I'm wrong
I'm not really seeing much detail on the
right or the left I'm seeing a lot of
detail in the center though okay let's
see There You Go the actual 50 megapixel
photo was on the left with the s23 we
both agreed that this one's the worst
yeah I don't know why it messed up the
colors look at the colors too I don't
know what happened there all the colors
look at this carpet and then right there
yeah it's really weird so the pixel to
my eyes looked the best but you like the
iPhone the best I saw a lot more detail
on that one huh next up this is an ultra
wide that's a cool looking shot against
the Sun so it's meant to be super tough
this is flare City yeah this has the
worst flaring yeah it kind of looks
magical but if you don't want that there
yeah between the center and the right to
the center has the least flaring however
all the colors are super messed up the
hdrs are really messed up the one on the
right everything outside looks beautiful
there's like some really nice glow in
her hair the colors look right I'm going
with the right one yeah look at the HDR
over here it's horrendous there's
nothing out there
um I go for the right one as well all
right
that's the s23 wow that looks the iPhone
suffers from really bad flaring wow now
this is a detail shot with 3x on all of
them which means that the iPhone is
digitally cropped into 3x same with a
pixel from the main camera and the s23
actually has a 3X lens it's surprising
even though it has a 3X lens they don't
look that much different it's crazy they
look so similar these all look great
they all look almost identical you have
to look so closely to try to see some
sort of difference
I'm gonna go with the left because on
some of these you can like really see
the brush strokes and all like the
details oh okay yeah you can also see
the what they had before yeah written on
there I'll go to the left as well
that's the pixel wow even without a
three inch lens dang next up we have
kind of like a macro shot or at least as
close as I could get now this one
definitely looks the closest yeah as far
as that looks nice uh this one looks the
least close but I do like how that looks
the most it's a tough choice though
because if you want to get close to a
bug or something else you want that
extra Zoom but then this one there's a
lot of detail in those leaves that's
true petals yeah I think you convinced
me I'll go with that one
oh I was gonna go with that one what
okay well let's vote again let's vote
separately
all right pixel on the left iPhone
that's right this is actually the
closest you can get that's a crop right
there yeah because
the iPhone does not have the macro mode
like the Pro Models get apple is just
limited everything oh my goodness this
is just a regular 1X no 50 megapixel on
the s23 I like how the left one is
brighter uh but there's a little bit too
much blown out area there as well so I
think the middle looks the most natural
to me I think the middle looks the worst
it looks a little too dark the left and
the right look basically
spread up a little more and I like that
so I'm going with the left okay left and
right iPhone and s23 here all right next
up we have a 3X to me the center and the
right one are a little too blown out
like his face just kind of loses some
detail so I'm picking the left one me
too it looks the most true to life you
have some natural a shadowing on the
face it looks realistic and I'm going
left that's the pixel once again it's
just killing all the three that's what
the digital crop too digital crop one
amazing maybe Samsung shouldn't have put
a 3X left yeah or put a better one I
don't know all right we have a portrait
portrait this is weird yeah what's going
on here Sky's blurred out but then the
trucks Stand Out parts of it aren't well
yeah this is a shop where it's typical
and you don't want to see the cars
that's why you put in the portrait mode
man that left one is so dark yeah I like
the song the Rays the color but it's
really dark it's so dark I think I'm
going to the right yeah default right
one
that's the iPhone kill those portraits
all right this is a cropped in detail
shot this one has a bunch of artifacting
lots of detail
um that kind of stuff the one on the
right also looks like it has a little
bit of a shutter lag or something a
little bit of smearing so I'm going for
the middle me too middle is the s23 in
50 megapixel modes wow it's a lot warmer
what color is the the cabinet or the
table it's it's like this basically
I have no idea why that mode is changing
it okay now this is a little bit
different this is 5X
has to be the center this is blown out
here that's really blurry Center looks
good
that is the pixel it actually has 5x
Optical looks amazing compared to from
1X digitally cropping in to 5x which is
the maximum this is a sunset shot yeah
you take these shots a lot of times
you're driving sunset's beautiful and
you want to get a photo I'm voting for
the middle it's the most Moody yep
that's the iPhone wow I guess the colors
really pop like the sunset colors and
everything okay now getting into the
night mode shots wow here is a portrait
on the main camera what's with the
center why does it look distorted
it does you look at her head it's
stretched out yeah this one looks very
almost like a little bit of
artifactiness or like digital crop but
like the right one is there's no detail
in her face they all kind of aren't
great this needs the s23 ultra and the
pro Max I think the left one is the best
in this situation I think I'll have to
agree I'll go with the left one
all right that's the pixel and that's
because you can't take a one exporter
you have to basically take 2x which I
got closer on the other two yeah but the
Galaxy stretched her out yeah next up
this is basically just night mode it was
very very dark in my hallway the left
one is really dark the center one looks
weird because you can't tell if it's day
or night or what's going on
the right one looks more natural to me I
think I'm gonna go with that I agree
so far the Samsung's not doing great at
night all right we have a night mode
selfie portrait so it's even more
difficult selfie portrait wow it just
gets worse that looks badass this looks
like iPhones five years ago potato
and I wonder if that's the iPhone if
Apple's limiting it uh I don't know what
that light's coming from I'm guessing it
shines a little bit of light and it's
blue or something I don't know you guys
look great in the left one yeah the left
one looks nice left oh my goodness it's
amazing yeah galaxy wow that's a great
selfie what's wrong with the iPhone I
think it's because with portrait mode it
needs more light and I guess it just I
don't know dude that Samsung looks great
and this is natural blur in the
background so it's not portrait mode but
not oh this is actually at night so
another night mode shot oh interesting
it's at night this is hard because that
looks like a morning shot to me right I
thought of colors and stuff but it looks
really good the bokeh looks the most
right uh like a DSLR too where this is
kind of busy over here these are dark
especially the left one that is super
dark so much of the details gone I'm
gonna go with the rice I'm still going
with the right too
pixel pixel wow killing it yeah we have
eight whoa Astro mode yep that's
astrophotography so each one had a
different shutter time keep that in mind
gotta be the left yeah there's way more
stars here that you don't get here yeah
so keep in mind I had it on a tripod
they were all standing and the left ones
the pixel because it had a four minute
exposure I even had 30 seconds and the
Galaxy had like 10 seconds only I don't
even know why it didn't go higher than
that I think they added that but just to
the ultra oh like a long one it's fifth
I'm correct oh man I will say that it's
a pain waiting four minutes I've done it
it's a pain so annoying and this is the
last one it was insanely dark like
almost Pitch Black it's Gotta Be the
rice it's so bright what
look at this you look it's like an alien
yeah this is blue this is like artifacty
and weird I think the face looks the
most natural in that I think the right
is almost as bad as the center one for
me the left one actually has some sort
of detail and looks a little more normal
the other two looks so bizarre to me
it's too warm and I don't love the
colors that the face like artificially
made like fake Photoshop blur or
something you know I'm gonna go with the
right I would add some warmth to it but
none look amazing okay the right is the
iPhone the left is the s23 what happened
to the pixel I thought this was the
pixel yeah all right guys that is the
last shot so go ahead and let us know in
the comments what you voted for or if
you didn't vote what surprises popped up
let's add this up I'm ready
12 for the iPhone 11 for the pixel so
almost a tie and then seven for the s23
the iPhone one how was the no telephoto
that's insane
I think the iPhone did terrible even
though sometimes they didn't choose it
it sucks that Apple's selling a 800
phone with cameras that are limiting in
so many in different ways but for me the
pixel one I got nine nine and then the
pixel got 13 and honestly I did think
the Samsung would perform better yeah
than what we got here and I think it's
just because the pixel took some of the
shots away yeah just the 3x lens is just
not performing that well yeah like
almost like if they would have just used
that 50 megapixel and cropped in like
the pixel is doing it would have had a
better result in some of those shots
there so thank you guys for watching
we're also gonna do one with s23 ultra
the pixel again and the 14 pro Max so
click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those videos right over
there and we'll see you in the next one
[Music]
thank you